John Smith boring just like his name
I think John Smith is real smelly got
like some smegma buildup I'm not John
Smith when you come from a family of
racists it's hard to change but he
changes which is hot or ring next Prince
or snow it looks like Liza Minnelli yeah
he kind of does look like a porcelain
doll he looks like a child he kinda
looks like Kris Jenner I wouldn't do it
hello I don't know but he's got the
swagger of someone that's hung would you
let him suck your dick no I want prince
charming Prince Philip's dressed like
it's easy season three Tootie looks like
Bieber that was just like Bieber he's
giving me a half trumpet pest would you
would I wake up from a deep slumber from
his kiss maybe cliche I got saved by
like Asian standards this guy's not a
good-looking guy what it's too strong
for me I would feel turned on if he
thought I was hot we'd have great
test-tube babies oh you know what though
he is rocking the man bun yeah that's
before his time um it's hard to judge an
animal on its hotness but let's try I
think
East is hotter see the claws teeth you
know like it you know like a rough
Ronnie I don't like that man I want to
walk away from my experience is this guy
a ginge yeah that's crazy that Disney
made the bold choice of making him a
ginge I prefer the Beast to Prince Adam
I mean I'll tell you that he is the most
ideal cuddle partner in the Disney
universe when Ryder
tangles no I don't know about this chin
scruff no he was almost evil like that's
a thing like with that guy looks evil
that guy's a freakin dreamboat I don't
fight people but he seems like someone
that I would want to get into a fight
with 100% he sort of looks like a cross
between you and me though I got that
Kristoff is definitely not chubby German
boy my mom I wasn't more chocolate he
looks like everyone I know from
Minnesota
I'm more into Olaf and Kristoff they
gave him like the shaggy hair cuz he's
in this cold environment why didn't they
just give him a beard that's he's
interesting dude they'd never give
Disney characters a beard because it
looks creepy
he looks pretty handsome I'm pretty sure
he's charming he's got a sense of humor
delightful accent he plays music he's
hot he is nicely built but he's not like
Hugh Jack Johnson how do these people
find like so much time to work out
Eric's I question his motives because
like when you I want to hook up with a
fish with a fish that's kind of weird if
you introduce me to your new boyfriend
and he looked like Prince Eric I
wouldn't trust him
no he's got blue eyes and black hair
he's got a dog he's romantic
also how come his dog couldn't talk but
all the sea animals could talk Aladdin
wins me over cuz he's a started from the
bottom now we're here kind of new
definitely the best
I think Aladdin smart you look at him
look at that's cute I've known that
magic carpet ride and I would not dare
close my eyes I'd say you settled down
with Aladdin and he knows how to rub the
lamp I got a pretty big lamp - I have an
accessible and moderately sized lamp I
want to see a Disney movie where two
peasants fall in love and neither of
them become rich yes or a prince ooh why
can't it just be like hey I'm a banker